c'était en avant citoyen un film réalisé
par Céline crispy bonjour juste à vos
côtés on accueille Camille Étienne
bonjour vous êtes militante écologiste
activiste pour la justice sociale et
climatique merci infiniment à toutes les
deux d'avoir accepté de participer à Z
la Zone d'Éducation documentaire alors
nous sommes à Eaubonne dans le
Val-d'Oise et ce sont les élèves du
collège André Chenier qui vont vous
poser plein de questions ils ont vu
évidemment le documentaire ils
connaissent vos actions mais juste avant
de leur laisser la parole j'aimerais
vous poser quelques questions d'abord
quand je vous dis le mot écologie vous
pensez à quoi oui sauver la planète le
recyclage
éco-responsable ok allez c'est à vous de
poser les questions et on commence avec
et on commence avec Elisa pourquoi
avez-vous choisi ce thème de l'écologie
alors moi j'ai pris ce thème parce que
il me semble que c'est le défi majeur du
21e siècle vous voyez le dérèglement
climatique remet en cause totalement nos
modes de vie et quelque part mais un peu
en péril notre survie à moyen terme ou à
long terme et donc il me paraissait
intéressant de voilà de de prendre de
parler de ça et de le faire à travers
des citoyens c'est à dire que on a
coutume de dire que les Français sont de
moins en moins intéressés par la
politique et moi j'ai fait le pari en
tout cas c'est ce que je ressentais en
tant que journaliste et reporters que il
y a des gens qui avaient envie de faire
de la politique autrement c'est à dire
simplement aller voter etc mais faire
changer les choses parce que faire de la
politique c'est aussi agir pour faire
changer les choses et faire évoluer la
société et donc de combiner un peu les
deux c'est à dire
l'impératif environnemental qui qui
devrait tous nous concerner et des
citoyens qui ont envie d'agir
concrètement et bien ça me paraissait un
bon documentaire dans votre documentaire
quel est le personnage que vous a le
plus touché
alors moi je les ai je les ai aimés tous
les trois mais je crois que celui qui
m'a le plus touché c'est Alexandra Néron
parce que d'abord elle est jeune et je
trouve que c'est à la jeune génération
aussi de s'emparer de ces questions là
parce qu'elle a une vraie vision
politique des choses parce qu'elle se
dit bah c'est le citoyen qui qui doit
faire puisque les politiques apparemment
ne font pas assez et puis voilà après
c'est une question de rencontre et je
l'ai trouvé très attachante et vous quel
est le personnage qui vous a le plus
marqué
Alice aussi
je trouve que le vrac c'était bien parce
que c'est compliqué vu que tout le monde
part en grande surface du coup bah le
vrac c'est plus c'est moins facile
d'accès ok du coup bah faut avoir du
courage quand même pour tenir une
épicerie de vrac parce que c'est
difficile tous les jours est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que c'est trois
personnages donc Alice Alexandra et
Xavier dans le documentaire on l'entend
on l'entend goutte d'eau dans la mer ou
goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le vase
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
leur trois actions
c'est vraiment des tout petits trucs
c'est vraiment des gouttes d'eau dans la
mer ça va rien changer ou est-ce que
vous avez l'impression au contraire que
c'est le début c'est le début d'un grand
changement oui dis-nous si par exemple
si ils font ces petites actions et que à
travers le documentaire il donne
l'exemple bah ça peut encourager
d'autres personnes à le faire donc non
bah c'est pas forcément des choses qui
servent à rien ok moi je dis que c'est
un peu les deux parce que c'est des
petites actions qui vont débloquer un
grand changement ok alors on va
continuer avec toi Billy qu'est-ce qui
vous a motivé à devenir militante pour
l'écologie écoute c'est pas c'est pas un
choix c'est pas je me suis pas réveillé
un matin en me disant c'est bon j'ai
envie d'être écolo j'ai trouvé ma
vocation comme si j'avais envie d'être
je sais pas boulangère ou peu importe
non c'est vraiment plus une nécessité
moi j'ai grandi à la montagne et du coup
j'ai vu ce quand tu parlais de fond des
glaces moi j'ai vu les glaciers vraiment
j'en parlais avec mes grands-parents et
je voyais que eux bah c'était c'était
fou parce que il y avait déjà des photos
de mes grands-parents de ma grand-mère à
mon âge qui était sur un classique qui
était beaucoup plus grand et le mien
quand je le voyais là maintenant je
parle en 2020 mais en fait il était
beaucoup plus il était en train de
disparaître et ça ça m'a profondément
touché et je pense que pas tout le monde
a besoin forcément de vivre près d'un
glacier ça peut être des choses autour
de chez vous peut-être que vous pouvez
trouver qu'il y a trop de béton ici et
pas et que vous aimeriez bien voir plus
de nature autour peut-être que ça peut
être parce que vous avez des gens qui
tombent malades à cause de la pollution
de l'air dans votre entourage enfin
c'est de trouver une raison qui m'a un
petit peu indignée et je me suis dit
mais là c'est injuste et si c'est
injuste qu'est-ce que je fais soit je
trouve ça triste et alors ben je reste
là comme ça et puis bah c'est comme ça
ou alors je me dis ok je vais me battre
contre ce qui a permis cet injustice et
c'est comme ça que je suis devenu
activiste pour le climat c'est parce que
j'ai commencé à vouloir me battre pour
juste ça peut être les déchets ça peut
être les glaciers et puis plus tu
creuses et plus tu vois des injustices
et plus tu as envie de te dire bah c'est
pas normal qu'on le laisse faire donc je
vais commencer par faire ma part et et
petit à petit partager et puis après
tout se déroule et on et on devient une
force un peu inarrêtable quels sont vos
trois principaux combats pour sauver la
planète mon combat du moment sur les
fonds marins moi je connaissais rien du
tout au fond marin donc si je vous dis
ça c'est aussi parce que on n'a pas
besoin on est légitime vous êtes
légitime quoi qui se passe d'où vous
venez moi je connaissais rien du tout
elle océan et pour autant je me bats
pour éviter que des bateaux ailles
chercher des minerais c'est des pierres
qui sont utiles pour les batteries par
exemple les batteries de téléphone et
tout ça qui peut être utile sauf qu'en
fait c'est hyper dangereux parce que
pour les baleines et tout ça et puis
aussi parce que ça libère ce qu'on
appelle enfin le carbone le CO2 qui est
capturé dans les fonds marins on dit
souvent que l'Amazonie la forêt c'est le
poumon de la planète en vrai c'est les
océans d'abord la moitié de l'oxygène
qu'on expire est bien l'océan donc moi
j'essaye de faire en sorte que les
bateaux ne réussissent pas à partir et
qu'on protège ses fonds marins puis
après pour aller plus rapidement sur les
deux autres il y en a un c'est une
Papeline en Ouganda entre l'Ouganda et
la Tanzanie et ce serait une bonne
climatique ce qu'on appelle c'est à dire
que ça mettrait plein de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère sauf qu'on a déjà assez
et la dernière je dirais que c'est
plutôt d'être là je pense que c'est ça
mon plus grand combat c'est que tout
seul on y arrivera à rien il faut pas
attendre d'avoir des héros ou des
héroïnes mais c'est vraiment de vous
donner l'énergie de vous dire que vous
êtes assez que vous êtes légitime que
vous êtes super important et importantes
parce que là où on est fort c'est quand
on est nombreux à votre avis ce que l'on
peut vivre uniquement de matériaux
recyclés ça supposerait de changer
complètement notre mode de
fonctionnement ça c'est certain une
chose à comprendre c'est qu'on va devoir
produire et consommer moins c'est sûr là
on produit trop on consomme trop mais
surtout de choses inutiles il y a plein
de choses qu'on a qui en vrai sont pas
utiles donc la première question à se
poser c'est se dire qu'est-ce qui compte
vraiment et à partir de ça en effet se
dire bah est-ce qu'on produirait pas ça
avec les matériaux qu'on a déjà extrait
parce qu'extraire des matériaux
l'extractivisme ce qu'on appelle ça
pollue en soi ça émet du CO2 ou tout un
tas d'autres gaz à effet de serre ça
prend des ressources naturelles qui sont
limitées donc il faudrait qu'on fasse le
moins possible on continue avec Diana
est-ce que les usines peut recycler les
déchets ne sont pas plus polluantes que
les déchets eux-mêmes en fait tu résumes
tout avec cette question c'est de dire
c'est pour ça que je disais qu'il faut
il va falloir produire moins c'est à
dire que même si c'est super important
et il faut qu'on recycle les matériaux
c'est sûr évidemment c'est comme il n'y
a pas d'énergie parfaitement propre en
fait tout ce qu'on fait va générer de la
pollution en plus et donc du coup
l'objectif c'est vraiment de se dire
comment est-ce qu'on réduit à la marge
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plein de français
françaises aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas le
choix de d'acheter du plastique tout le
temps d'acheter plein d'emballages de
consommer à de l'industriel parce que
c'est moins cher et donc comment est-ce
qu'on fait en sorte que ce soit
accessible à tout le monde c'est moi qui
m'intéresse aussi et yo bon continuez
avec toi madame Crespi quel impact
souhaiteriez-vous que ce reportage est
sur le mouvement écologique qui serait
consommateur
alors ben moi j'adorerais qu'il y a un
impact et c'est vrai que quand on fait
des documentaires quand on fait des
films quand on est journaliste c'est ça
qu'on a envie c'est un peu voilà tirer
la sonnette d'alarme et que et qui est
qui est un impact alors je pense que ça
peut plus savoir un impact sur les
consommateurs parce que finalement le
téléspectateur il peut se laisser
surprendre à regarder ce documentaire et
à se dire bah ouais finalement le vrac
c'est pas si compliqué que ça ah oui bah
tiens il me semble qu'il y a une
épicerie qui s'est mise il y a pas
longtemps et puis à prendre conscience
moi par exemple en tant que journaliste
alors que je connaissais déjà le sujet
ce qui m'a impressionné c'est quand je
suis allé dans ce centre de tri on voit
ces montagnes de déchets
nos déchets Alexandra Xavier et Alice
les ont pris pour cibles ce produit par
notre consommation conséquences du mythe
de la croissance infinie rebut de notre
civilisation
en fait je suis arrivé là et je me suis
dit et ben bon sang on regarde et là on
reconnaît ben un ancien balais enfin
tout ce qu'on a chez nous en fait et on
se dit et ben finalement à chaque fois
qu'on a un objet il a une fin de vie et
cette fin de vie bah c'est là comme si
c'était un petit peu l'aboutissement de
notre société de consommation où on
achète des choses sans y penser bah oui
on fait ses courses etc et donc ce que
j'aimerais c'est que ce documentaire il
est un petit peu cet impact modestement
j'espère qu'il qui l'aura sur les gens
en se disant et oui une prise de
conscience voilà
on continue avec Liam ce reportage
a-t-il eu un impact sur vos habitudes
écologiques si oui lesquels j'ai plus
aujourd'hui tendance à consommer en vrac
etc etc parce qu'en fait quand on achète
quelque chose on a l'impression que ça
coûte cher en fait ça coûte ça coûte
rien imaginez un petit jouet un petit
jouet voyez que il y a quelques années
on vous offrait dans un dans un Happy
Meal pour pas le citer aujourd'hui c'est
plus autorisé mais ce petit jouet en
fait ce petit jouet on nous le donne
gratuitement donc il nous coûte rien
voilà il va on va jouer cinq minutes
avec et puis après c'est terminé en fait
ce petit jouet il a fallu du plastique
il a fallu tirer des ressources souvent
il a été fait au bout du monde donc il a
fallu du transport pour l'apporter etc
et en fait c'est une telle conséquence
sur l'environnement que tout est
disproportionné en fait l'intérêt qu'on
a nous de ce petit jouet et finalement
le coût pour la planète et donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je suis plus regardante
dans ce que dans ce que j'achète et
notamment en termes de de bien
technologique le portable et téléphone
tant que ça marche en fait il y a pas
besoin de changer les trucs
et vous en regardant le documentaire
est-ce que ça vous a est-ce que ça vous
a fait changer de regard est-ce que
quand vous avez vu justement cette
montagne de déchets elles sont hyper
impressionnantes c'est enfin moi elles
m'ont impressionné ces images voici ça
vous a impressionné vous saviez qu'il y
avait des montagnes comme ça de déchets
dans des usines de recyclage oui
dis-nous ce qui m'a plus impressionné
c'est je m'en souviens plus du jeu du
nombre exact ou exact de déchets qu'il y
a dans la mer et c'est ça qui m'a
impressionné est-ce que vous êtes dit
moi qu'est-ce que je pourrais faire moi
d'essayer d'acheter de moins de choses
inutiles qui jouent aux jeux vidéos
voilà est-ce que vous achetez est-ce que
vous achetez des jeux d'occasion moi
j'ai toujours acheté des jeux d'occasion
c'est un système qui a toujours
fonctionné pourquoi on le fait pas pour
tout le reste qui a des jeux d'occasion
ça vous semble normal non
on va pas acheter un jeu tout neuf vous
voyez est-ce que est-ce que ce déclic là
on peut l'avoir pour d'autres choses
pour les voitures par exemple aussi bien
sûr acheter une voiture d'occasion les
téléphones téléphone d'occasion bien sûr
c'est des économies
un petit peu quand même
mais c'est bien je crois que c'était
intéressant qu'on est cette discussion
parce que c'est enfin en fait c'est
facile aussi de se dire il faut qu'on
achète d'occasion tout ça sauf qu'en
fait à baigné dans une société de
consommation on est né dedans qui a été
décidé par nos parents et donc parfois
l'idée l'image qu'on a de ce qu'elle
être la réussite de ce qui est belle
elle va être dirigée va dirigée vers
cette consommation toujours effrénée on
n'est pas super libre on imagine que que
on fait que ce qu'on veut et tout ça
mais on est toute la journée que ce soit
la publicité que ce soit la publicité
sur les réseaux sociaux aussi on baigne
dans un monde qui nous pousse à
consommer tout le temps donc il faut
déjà en avoir conscience et en prendre
conscience pour essayer de s'en extraire
un petit peu on poursuit avec toi est-ce
que certains de vos idées ont fait
avancer la cause écologique
l'intégralité de mes journées et vers
cet objectif là après moi je crois pas
du tout au gestion individuel j'ai
l'impression que mes idées moi tout seul
elles sont pas très intéressantes en
revanche là où elles sont puissantes
c'est quand elles donnent envie à
d'autres de nous rejoindre et quand on
s'organise ensemble pour un but précis
mais là c'est incroyable ce qu'on peut
faire moi je vous invite à essayer
vraiment c'est à essayer même localement
chez vous là ici dans ce collège là
qu'est-ce que vous voudriez porter comme
comme combat dans ce collège mieux
manger à la cantine à avoir des choses
locales avoir un compost ici enfin par
quoi voudrais commencer là tout de suite
faire un je sais pas envie de dressing
géant dans le collège avec des trucs
cool trouver le peut-être c'est une des
nuls mais justement c'est vous qui avez
les meilleures idées et ce serait trop
génial que vous vous décidiez ensemble
d'un projet que vous disiez comment
est-ce qu'on le fait advenir et puis
vous verrez qu'après c'est là où en fait
on a l'impression qu'on change vraiment
le monde parce que on change d'abord un
autre monde et notre rapport au monde et
ça c'est super puissant on poursuit avec
toi Emma qu'attendez-vous des
politiciens sur le sujet de l'écologie
et avez-vous déjà été reçu par l'Elysée
pour faire part de vos idées jamais été
reçu par l'Élysée par des ministres de
ce gouvernement là quelques-uns déjà un
petit peu beaucoup à l'Assemblée
nationale donc tout ça mais non ce que
j'attends très simplement c'est de
c'est de d'être à la hauteur de l'enjeu
et de tenir leurs promesses et peut-être
de cesser nous mépriser aussi de cesser
ce mépris qui fait que ils remettent
toute la pression sur les gens et donc
on a l'impression que c'est nous qui
sommes pas assez bien c'est toujours la
faute de ceux qui peuvent le moins donc
moi ce que j'attends c'est qu'il
réussisse à faire payer ceux qui sont
vraiment responsables c'est que ce soit
ces grandes multinationales qui qui
fassent le plus d'efforts c'est que ce
soit c'est
ultra riches qui arrête de prendre un
jet privé qui est des vraies lois
concrètes pour que les responsables des
émissions payent d'abord et que chacun
fasse selon ses moyens ça ce serait
vraiment très cool Julia tu voulais
rajouter quelque chose moi j'ai une
question qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
actions des activistes écolo si par
exemple blog des routes ou qui jettent
de la soupe sur des tableaux c'est une
super question vous pensez que c'est
trop extrême ou pas Eliot tu voulais
ajouter quelque chose bah on peut dire
que ce qu'ils font c'est extrême mais au
moins après on les écoute
fait que leur seul moyen de se faire
voir ok du coup Camille tu sais que ça
t'offre elle a pas été gâché c'était sur
la sur la vitre qui protégeait la le
tableau et qu'au bout de 10 minutes ils
ont tout nettoyé et que il y a rien de
il y a certaines actions qu'on va faire
pour plaire pour rassembler plein monde
autour de nous pour embarquer tout le
monde faire des marches tout ça pour que
les gens s'engagent il y a des fois où
en fait on va pas chercher à plaire mais
à déranger il y a déranger ça veut dire
bousculer l'ordre en place c'est de se
dire puisque on nous met pas des caméras
sur nous bah c'est pas grave on va
monter sur scène et on va prendre le
micro parce qu'on nous donne pas la
parole et c'est ça qu'ils ont voulu
faire c'est à dire se dire on va aller
là où on va déranger assez pour qu'on
nous écoute enfin donc c'est des gens
qui sont un peu de forme de désespoir de
se dire on crie dans le vide et ben tant
pis on va prendre le mégaphone et parler
et je comprends que ça puisse bousculer
moi les moi qui adorent enfin j'utilise
beaucoup l'art pour mobiliser et tout
l'idée de se dire ça te quitter un œuvre
d'art au début j'étais là ah sûr vous
êtes sûr et en fait je dis ok ça m'a
dérangé et ça a créé un débat et là
c'est intéressant Samia pensez-vous que
les politiques sont responsables du
changement climatique responsable on
l'est tous un peu puisque c'est nos
modes de vie mais là où ils sont
responsables c'est que
en fait aujourd'hui on dit qu'un pays il
va bien quand il a de la croissance
économique ça vous en avez tous entendu
parler on dirait alors combien on va
avoir croissance de pourcent de
croissance 3% de croissance 4% de
croissance en fait ça veut dire qu'il
faut toujours produire plus produire
plus consommer plus donc c'est pour ça
qu'on achète de plus en plus ce qu'on
nous donne envie à travers la publicité
d'acheter d'acheter d'acheter et on se
dit ah bah ça c'est une société qui va
bien donc je pense que là où le
politique il est il est responsable
c'est d'abord qu'il a le pouvoir et qui
est qu'en plus il continue avec ces
vieilles façons de penser le monde et
ces vieilles façons de penser le monde
c'est de penser que plus on a de
croissance et plus la société va bien
bah non aujourd'hui on n'a pas assez de
ressources le réchauffement climatique
il a il arrive donc il faut penser
autrement l'économie et
ça veut pas dire que parce qu'on va
avoir moins de croissance économique on
va avoir moins de bonheur au contraire
au contraire et je pense que c'est là où
le politique il a pas encore pris la
mesure de ce qui arrivait pourquoi selon
visage pas parce qu'ils ont peur du
changement je pense qu'en fait on a tous
peur du changement et que eux bah s'ils
prennent des décisions du jour au
lendemain s'ils disent bah voilà on
arrête ça on continue ça et donc ils
préfèrent essayer de faire à moitié un
petit peu avec avec des vieux modèles on
continue avec toi Eliot que les actions
écologiques comme celles contenu dans
votre reportage peuvent toucher et
influencer les politiciens ça part un
peu prétentieux j'espère moi je fais ce
encore une fois ce métier pour ça mais
bon je pense que les solutions en fait
il les connaissent ils ont pas besoin de
mon documentaire
après il y a toute une réflexion qui
avait été faite sur le vrac pendant que
je réalisais le documentaire et qui va
obliger à partir de 20 à toutes les
grandes surfaces donc supermarché et
hypermarchés qui sont encore les les
endroits où la majorité la grande
majorité des gens achètent de proposer
20% donc un cinquième du volume en vrac
donc ça c'est barbara Pompili qui avait
mis ça dans son projet de loi climat et
résilience donc ça c'est voilà c'est un
petit plus mais pour moi ça va pas assez
loin voilà ça va pas assez loin mais là
où pour rebondir un petit peu sur ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure bien sûr que
nous citoyens vous citoyens de demain
vous devez faire mais je pense que les
politiques à un moment faut un peu les
pousser c'est à dire qui eux aussi ils
ont envie ils ont ils ont besoin d'être
un peu dans l'air du temps donc s'il
voit ces mouvements citoyens prendre des
initiatives demander etc etc ils vont un
petit peu être obligés de le faire quel
métier vous en pensez quoi de cette loi
moi cette loi c'était c'est trop bien il
y avait 150 citoyens que c'était réuni
ça s'appelait la convention citoyenne
pour le climat qui avait été tiré au
sort et tout qui avait décidé 150
mesures pour que la France réduit ses
émissions et puis le président avait dit
bah je traduirai vos mesures en une loi
concrète sauf que cette loi elle avait
été torpillée nous on était super déçu
parce que c'était beaucoup de travail de
plein de Français qui avaient donné de
leur temps des citoyens et du coup on
s'est dit bah ok on va camper dans
l'Assemblée nationale on va aller camper
pour que nos députés viennent nous voir
donc on a commencé à 5 amis vraiment et
puis petit à petit il y a eu un député
de députés 3 députés et on a on a eu des
gens qui venaient partout en France pour
être là et être avec nous pendant ces
trois semaines de débat dans cette
fameuse place sérieux ça c'était c'était
génial donc là je me suis beaucoup
battue pour que cette loi climat elle
reprennent un peu de sa vigueur et c'est
c'était ce genre d'action c'est que vous
pouvez faire en tant que citoyen c'est
pas juste vous changer vos modes de
consommation mais s'engager comme ça
collectivement et rejoindre ce genre
d'action c'est c'est assez fou pour être
très précis fin du chauffage sur les
terrasses le 20% de vrac à partir de
arrêtez de louer les passoires
thermiques etc c'est quoi c'est rien
c'est quand même bien non c'est pas moi
qui dit que c'est pas assez c'est
simplement factuellement on est en train
de dépasser ce qu'on appelle des seuils
des limites planétaires c'est comme si
je sais pas on était en train de marcher
au bar au bord de cette salle là et que
chaque génération disait un petit peu en
pâte plus sauf que non on est vraiment
la génération si on fait le pas de plus
et ben on tombe dans le vide donc c'est
super important ce qui joue maintenant
donc face à cette urgence là
factuellement dire ah on va arrêter de
chauffer les terrasses dans 10 ans ou on
fera un petit peu de vrac quand même en
2030 non mais vous rendez compte en 2030
moi j'aurais 32 ans rien qu'en 2050 il y
a plus de plastique que de poissons les
océans mais ça n'a aucun sens de dire oh
on va interdire les fourchettes en
plastique enfin c'est bien mignon mais
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin que ça
il faut être courageux un petit peu et
puisque eux a priori ne le sont pas
assez bah il va falloir que non soit
courageux dans dans ce qu'on va leur
demander
Mariama en quoi l'économie circulaire
est une solution pour sauver la planète
alors l'économie circulaire c'est c'est
une très bonne idée c'est à dire
qu'encore une fois c'est éviter d'aller
puiser des ressources se dire bah voilà
le plastique on en a on va faire on va
on va réutiliser etc etc mais pour moi
c'est c'est que quand on peut pas faire
autrement c'est à dire que en fait si je
vous dis qu'est-ce qui est mieux de
recycler sa bouteille plastique ou de
prendre sa gourde à votre avis
parce qu'en fait tout se plastique même
le recyclage il y avait ça tout à
l'heure dans ta question même ce
recyclage il produit il on a besoin de
l'énergie une autre image moi qui m'a
qui m'a frappé quand j'ai fait ce
documentaire c'est quand on va dans
l'usine qui refait du fil avec le
plastique Xavier découvre que le
filateur espagnol a investi pour assurer
une fibre recyclée avec les mêmes
qualités qu'une matière plastique
industriel quoi c'est costaud je voyais
il y avait de l'énergie partout c'était
une vraie usine on avait l'impression et
en fait je me disais enfin est-ce que
tout ça a du sens donc l'économie
circulaire ouais c'est super mais le
mieux encore une fois c'est beaucoup de
moins consommer en fait et encore une
fois de pas se dire la croissance
acheter acheter en fait faut tout ce
qu'on qu'on arrête d'acheter en fait on
vit comme des nantis on se rend pas
compte on consomme beaucoup trop non
mais juste le meilleur des chefs c'est
su qu'on produit pas et le déchet c'est
inventé par l'humain la question pour
moi c'est de comment est-ce qu'on arrête
cette logique qui crée qui crée du
déchet en fait ça c'est fondamental
Yanis on continue avec toi pensez-vous
que les personnes qui ne s'engagent pas
pour l'écologie sont irresponsables tu
penses à qui
des citoyens il y en a vous il y en a
d'entre vous qui sont l'impression de
pas s'engager
et pourquoi
vous sentez loin de ça ça vous concerne
pas
les choses par exemple qu'on a vu dans
le reportage moi je les ai jamais faite
par exemple sur recyclage ou tout ce qui
est accès à ça ou parce que tu avais pas
pensé c'est plus quoi c'est plus que
j'ai pas accès par exemple le vrac j'ai
pas accès et surtout que j'ai pas pensé
surtout
je pourrais en vouloir à quelqu'un par
exemple qui vient pas avec moi en
manifestation le vendredi ou le samedi
parce que il doit faire trois jobs pour
payer ses études parce que on n'a pas
accès être écolo n'est pas facile
aujourd'hui pour tout le monde d'autant
plus quand on n'est pas les plus
privilégiés et ça c'est super important
de le comprendre c'est à dire que
comment est-ce qu'on fait maintenant
pour créer une société où on a accès à
ses choix et donc là ce qui est
intéressant dans ce que vous avez dit
c'est comment est-ce qu'on réclame ce
choix c'est ça qui m'intéresse et pour
moi c'est ça qui est puissant c'est à
dire de d'aller dire mais c'est pas
normal pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a pas de
compost du tout autour de nous on est
pourquoi c'est pas c'est on n'a pas le
droit de trier nos recycler complètement
nos déchets organiques je suis sûr que
si il y a c'est écrit ou même toute la
classe décrivait une lettre au maire
d'ici mais ce serait je suis sûr que
avec vous signatures à vous et vos
discours à vous il y a potentiellement
ça peut fonctionner c'est ça que je sais
vous faire prendre conscience donc moi
jamais je pourrais en vouloir à ceux qui
ne se sont pas écolos mais parce qu'ils
ne peuvent pas ils n'ont pas cette
option du choix et donc là où devient
intéressant pour moi c'est quand du coup
on fait de cette de cette injustice une
indignation qu'on transforme en une
action et là ça devient super puissant
Victoria selon vous pour quelle raison
la population française ne se sent pas
ou très peu concerné par l'écologie
bah moi je pense que la population
française elle se sent concernée
regardez tout à l'heure quand on a dit
écologique est-ce que ça évoque tout le
monde avait des tas de mots à dire etc
et d'autant plus depuis cet été on a été
tous très choqués par les températures
extrêmement hautes par les feux de
forêts par voilà toutes ces catastrophes
climatiques qui arrivent et qui arrivent
beaucoup plus vite que ce qu'on
imaginait finalement donc je pense que
les gens se sentent concernés simplement
c'est comment passer à l'action et
comment transformer d'abord une forme de
sidération et de peur on parle souvent
de gens qui sont éco anxieux c'est à
dire ah oui mon Dieu est-ce qu'il va y
avoir la fin du monde est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir vivre dans 10 ans 20 ans comme
on vit aujourd'hui en action et en fait
c'est c'est voilà comment passer à
l'action c'est peut-être ça après nous
ce qu'on peut se dire c'est changer un
peu les choses et peut-être changer
aussi peut-être nos rêves changer nos
rêves est-ce que est-ce que c'est super
de penser qu'un influenceur qui habite à
Dubaï qui polluent
qui fait que faire des trucs pour pour
nous faire acheter des choses et qui en
plus payent pas ces impôts en France
est-ce que c'est ça un modèle en fait
c'est peut-être nous aussi à essayer de
voir
quels sont quels sont nos rêves voilà et
du coup de faire passer pour ceux qu'on
a considéré comme des gagnants pour
finalement des has bean quoi on aurait
pu les trouver super au 20e siècle mais
là ils sont pas du tout dans dans dans
ce qu'il faut tout ce qui est important
aujourd'hui
quel serait les solutions pour que le
coût de l'écologie ne freine pas les
ambitions des citoyens c'est une vaste
question bah en fait ça dépend ce qu'on
a comme ambition et ça dépend la société
qu'on veut en fait la société
que vous vous voulez encore une fois je
reviens sur cet exemple qui peut
paraître un peu bébête mais est-ce que
nos rêves est-ce que réussir dans la vie
c'est de se dire qu'on va à Dubaï trois
fois par an pour aller faire des courses
ou est-ce que c'est de se dire que bah
en fait on mange vachement bien parce
que on connaît le paysan d'à côté et
qu'on a moins de bien et qu'on a
peut-être plus de liens entre les gens
pour moi j'ai envie de te répondre comme
ça je sais pas si je réponds bien à ta
question mais j'ai envie de te répondre
comme ça c'est quoi qui vous manque vous
toi tu aimerais bien que ça ressemble à
quoi pour toi là juste vivre ici de
manière plus écologique ce serait quoi
est-ce que le fait par exemple je te
donne une idée comme ça le fait qui est
peut-être moins de voitures est-ce que
ça c'est quelque chose qui te qui te
parlerait le fait que par exemple pour
toi un environnement qui sera un tout
petit peu plus écologique ce serait que
on se déplace plus en vélo tout
simplement non pas un vélo mais en fait
on
va chez électrique ouais ok
la fumée qui soit par derrière voilà
name pensez-vous qu'on puisse équilibrer
le confort de vie et l'écologie alors ta
question elle est très intéressante
parce que c'est souvent ce qu'on nous
dit c'est souvent ce qu'on dit ah ben
non ben oui mais si on veut être écolo
bah en fait faut renoncer voilà on
imagine même il y a des hommes
politiques très haut placés qui dit mais
enfin vous voulez vivre un petit peu
comme des amis etc vous avez peut-être
déjà entendu cette cette expression et
ben en fait moi je pense tout le
contraire je pense tout le contraire
parce que par exemple si on prend une
des mesures
qui est essentiel aujourd'hui pour
réduire notre impact c'est de mieux
isoler les les logements alors ça paraît
comme ça un petit peu pas très sexy
comme question ni très mais en fait
c'est capital c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui il y a plein de bâtiments
qui sont mal isolés du coup on
chauffe-eau c'est comme si on chauffait
dehors donc ça n'a pas de sens et ben là
si on isole mieux c'est bien pour la
planète parce que du coup après on va
avoir moins de consommation d'énergie
mais c'est vachement mieux pour les
habitants et puis en plus c'est
économique tout à l'heure tu disais
écologique économique donc en fait il y
a pas forcément d'opposition on continue
avec toi pensez-vous que la situation
climatique est encore rattrapable
actuellement il faut faire beaucoup
d'efforts voilà j'ai envie de dire ça il
faut il faut on pourra pas revenir en
arrière
mais il faut il faut qu'on fasse
beaucoup d'efforts il faut vraiment sans
mauvais jeu de mots passer la seconde
quoi faut vraiment y aller pas avec des
petites mesurettes en fait faut changer
de modèle de société c'est ça qui mais
c'est pas forcément c'est pas forcément
triste en fait pas du tout il y a de
l'espoir ou pas Camille ouais après il
faut aussi être lucide sur le fait que
on va vivre des conséquences des
règlements climatiques de plus en plus
il y a une inertie aussi de des
émissions qui sont émises et qui restent
très très longtemps dans l'atmosphère
pour certains gaz c'est dire qu'il faut
qu'on sache qu'on va rentrer dans une
forme d'incertitude donc on va avoir de
plus en plus de feux de forêt sûrement
nous notre génération va connaître de
plus en plus des inondations donc il
faut y être prêt il faut avoir le
courage de de la lucidité de se dire ok
ça arrive c'est on va se préparer plus
on fait le courage de savoir vraiment ce
qui nous arrive plus aussi on se rend
compte qu'on peut on peut s'adapter à ça
de plus en plus et puis qu'on peut
éviter une immense partie juste pour
finir il y a cette idée que faire le
deuil qu'on va changer le monde j'ai
toujours dit ok on va tout le monde et
tout on va déjà réussir à changer un peu
notre monde et à le dérouter dérouter
c'est vraiment dire ok il y a cette
espèce d'autoroute de la croissance et
tout comme tu disais bah là on va
peut-être essayer de de décaler un peu
le chemin de faire un pas de côté rien
que pour ça en fait ça vaut le coup de
se battre Maëlys est-ce que vous serez
susceptible de refaire un reportage dans
les années à venir afin de connaître la
révolution ah bah oui moi j'adore
j'adorerais retourner voir mes trois
personnages Xavier
Alice et Alexandra pour voir
effectivement comment d'abord eux ils
ont évolué dans leur tête et comment
concrètement
il se ils ont fait évoluer leurs projets
mais je suis sûr qu'il qui qui
continueront concrètement il
m'expliquait eux ils avaient tous eu un
changement de vie sauf Alexandra qui
était jeune et qui s'était engagé assez
jeune dans ce combat là mais Xavier
comme Alice ils avaient connu autre
chose Xavier je vous le rappelle lui il
travaillait pour des entreprises pour
chercher du pétrole donc il avait fait
un sacré chemin dans sa tête et en fait
il disait que quand il vivait plus en
accord avec avec ses convictions ça le
rendait heureux et Alice c'est pareil en
faisant ces petites épiceries en vrac et
en essayant etc elle disait rien que
d'agir en fait ça rend heureux et même
si c'est à petit à petit échelle est-ce
que est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles
de la concrètement aujourd'hui et ce
qu'ils savent que leur documentaire
enfin en tout cas que les images que
vous avez tourné d'eux seront diffusées
des élèves qu'est-ce qu'ils en pensent
alors je leur ai dit je leur ai dit je
les ai appelé pour le pour le leur dire
donc ils étaient ravis et donc j'ai pris
des nouvelles effectivement donc
Alexandra elle elle a arrêté en fait son
association de ramassage etc parce
qu'elle s'est fait embaucher par une
collectivité locale qui malgré son jeune
âge la mise responsable justement
d'organiser sur tout un territoire au
nord de Bordeaux la collègue de bio
déchets et de mettre un plus grand
échelle son projet donc ça c'était
formidable et elle m'a raconté à quel
point d'ailleurs le documentaire avait
eu un impact sur ce recrutement parce
qu'en fait il avait été par les gens de
voilà de la collectivité de Libourne qui
qui l'ont recruté à la suite de ça donc
c'est formidable Xavier lui il passe
d'une association à la création d'une
entreprise et il veut élargir le champ
des possibles en plus des déchets marins
il veut revaloriser les déchets
notamment dans les déchetteries qui
contrairement à ce qu'on croit son
parfois enfouis PAF parfois brûlés enfin
tout n'est pas recyclé donc lui il veut
continuer voilà et Alice et ben elle a
toujours ces trois épiceries et elle me
dit que c'est difficile parce
qu'effectivement l'inflation et on
revient sur des questions de moyens le
covid etc tout ça la vachement ralenti
et c'est pas évident voilà c'est pas
évident mais elle garde ses trois
épiceries elle a toujours beaucoup
d'énergie quand vous voyez Camille cette
classe qui vous pose plein de questions
là pendant un petit temps qu'est-ce que
vous vous dites
l'impression d'avoir
une classe qui a envie de se de
reprendre en main ce qui paraît nous
échapper et ça ça c'est là où se joue
tout pour moi donc je suis assez content
de nous avoir rencontré est-ce que
est-ce que ça vous parle tout ça dis-moi
Samir avec toutes ces questions mon
point de vue que j'ai sur la cloche à la
changer je trouve d'accord ok moi je
voudrais recycler maintenant tu voudrais
ok super David
forcément besoin d'attendre des
politiques pour agir ok on s'arrête là
merci infiniment à toutes les deux pour
ces échanges passionnants les missions
et déjà terminé merci bravo les élèves
vous pouvez vous applaudir on peut aussi
remercier vos professeurs au fond de la
classe qui vous ont aidé à préparer
cette émission et puis nous on se
retrouve très vite avec un nouveau film
et une nouvelle classe parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'âge pour questionner le monde et
ces images salut les élèves
[Musique]